la sncf rachète le statut des cheminots
démissionné et signé un nouveau contrat
plus avantageux financièrement c'est ce
que propose la société ferroviaire à ces
cheminots condition sinequanone ces
derniers abandonnent le précieux statut
associés à leurs fonctions mais le
mystère règne sur le montant de
l'augmentation salariale
un sujet qui semble tabou au sein de
l'entreprise celle ci invoque le secret
professionnel et on en parle avec fabien
villedieu délégué syndical sud rail
bonjour fabien ville dieu merci de
répondre à nos questions quel est votre
regard sur cette pratique arrangement à
l'amiable ou tour ne pas se passe vous
imaginez bien que c'est un regard plutôt
critique
en tout cas il a le fait que ça sorte ça
au moins deux myrys le 1er mai rixe et
ça montre la volonté de la direction de
se séparer du statut alors même qu'elle
n'a plus besoin d'avoir dit avoir en
cours depuis le 1er janvier 2000 par
dire que depuis le 1er janvier 2001 tous
les embauchés à la sncf sont ce qu'on
appelle les contractuels certains des
agents qui n'ont pas le statut et malgré
le fait que elle n'a plus besoin de
passer par un statut pas embaucher a
priori ça ne va pas suffisamment vite et
donc elle essaye de se débarrasser du
statut en proposant la carotte et la
carotte c'est le salaire et c'est la
deuxième chose qui arrive à la tornade
dans ces que sa seconde contrairement à
ce qu'on avait pu croire ce que beaucoup
de gens pensent que les cheminots
seraient mieux payés que dans la plupart
des réseaux d'entreprises notamment dans
le privé eh bien ça prouve exactement là
sera lesquels sont têtus lorsque les
gens disent à la sncf était soit vous
monter mon salaire soit je pars dans le
privé parce que dans le privé ont connu
une augmentation de salaire par rapport
à ce que je gagne aujourd'hui à la sncf
ça prouve et ça réveille d'une chose
c'est que bas à formation est un métier
à responsabilités équivalentes
il ya des salaires qui sont aujourd'hui
plus élevés dans le privé qu'à la sncf
mais ça tombe bien c'est ce que disent
les organisations syndicales depuis des
années des années donc ça aura au moins
le mérite de montrer ces deux choses 1
que la direction veut se débarrasser du
statut et accélérer les choses et deux
cas un problème de rémunération à la
sncf mais qu'est-ce qui a gagné
et qu'est ce qui a à perdre justement
pour les cheminots quel est le montant
de cette augmentation
ça semble être un sujet un peu tabou est
ce que vous avez les chiffres et
qu'est-ce qui a gagné également pour la
sncf de son côté écouter ce qu'il ya à
gagner s'est débarrassé du statut voilà
tout le monde a bien compris que le
statut a un côté relativement protecteur
au part relativement c'est que le statut
évite les licenciements non pas les
licenciements mais les licenciements
économiques
je rappelle que si un cheminot fait une
bêtise une faute professionnelle statut
ça vous empêche pas de le virer voilà
donc ça permet à la sncf de se
débarrasser de ce statut qu'elle estime
soit obsolète ce soit trop cher
après effectivement on a du mal à avoir
exactement est ce que ces 300 400 à 700
euros vous imagine bien que tout ça est
un peu tabou mais en tout cas nous notre
volonté c'est dans cette histoire de
montrer qu'à un vrai problème de
salaires à la sncf etc au lieu de 6 et
trouver les solutions individuelles
on a essayé en voir et gratter auprès de
la sncf de troquer statut vis-à-vis de
l'augmentation de salaire eh ben il
serait grand temps que la sncf augmente
réellement les salaires de l'ensemble
des cheminots et sauro au moins cette
histoire aura moins mairie le mérite de
montrer qu'il ya un problème de pouvoir
d'achat chez les cheminées aujourd'hui
mais justement quels sont les chiffres
cette augmentation salariale ne filtre
pas est ce que vous vous en savez un peu
plus de votre côté on parle de plusieurs
centaines d'euros
nous ce qu'on sait c'est que la
fourchette serait entre 400 et 700 euros
bruts on est rarement en est
et est-ce que vous avez des chiffres
aussi sur le nombre de cheminots qui
décident de franchir le pas est ce que
vous vous rangez votre goût aujourd'hui
ils seraient une dizaine voilà enfin
c'est ce qu'on le problème c'est que
vous imaginez bien quand on interpelle
la direction de la sncf
elle nous répond pas voilà donc nous on
est obligé de voir établissement par
établissement re de faire le recensement
pour savoir est ce que vous êtes au
courant de ça et c'est vrai que l'
avantage le fait que ça soit sortie dans
la presse je pense que les masques vont
tomber on aura un peu plus de retour
aujourd'hui les retours qu'on a ça
serait
une dizaine d'agents alors c'est
effectivement minoritaire mais dans un
contexte où la sncf essaye de se
débarrasser du statut parce qu'elle n'a
plus besoin d'y avoir recours du 1er
janvier 2001 et dans un contexte où on
sent qu'elle essaye de gratter un petit
peu partout ce qui est aujourd'hui
minoritaire peut très rapidement devenir
généraliser d'ici quelques mois si on
n'y prend pas garde
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions enfin vie dieu je rappelle que
vous êtes délégué syndical sud rail